[Musik]
was verbirgt sich hinter dem
neoliberalismus erst eine variante des
liberalismus dabei soll der staat so
viel wie nötig so wenig wie möglich in
den markt eingreifen zurück der
neoliberalismus auf ein treffen von
ökonomen in paris 1938
sie sahen den neoliberalismus als
antwort auf faschismus und kommunismus
für den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
braucht es einen starken wettbewerb in
der freien wirtschaft sagen die
befürworter
flexible märkte kämen verbraucher über
niedrigere preise und bessere produkte
zugute
der staat schaffe hierfür nur den rahmen
im angelsächsischen raum hat sich der
neoliberalismus anders entwickelt seit
den 80ern hat sich der begriff
neoliberalismus zu einem kampfbegriff
gewandelt der vor allem für markt
radikales denken steht mit der
ursprungsidee eines ordnung starts vor
und nach dem zweiten weltkrieg hat er
mal mehr mal weniger zu tun
ein anhänger war der frühere us
präsident ronald reagan er regierte in
den 80ern um glaubte an den sogenannten
trickle down effekt reichtum komme durch
konsum und investitionen zu den ärmsten
regen senkte daher massiv die steuern
zwar wuchs das os amerikanische
bruttoinlandsprodukt in der folge stark
gleichzeitig verdreifachten sich die
staatsschulden in acht jahren
zudem verteilen sich die einkommen und
vermögen seit seiner regierung in den
usa immer ungleicher wie auch weltweit
weltweite krisen haben die grenzen des
marktradikalen neoliberalismus gezeigt
bei der wirtschafts und finanzkrise 2008
musste der staat für banken einspringen
in der korona krise sind es vor allem
staatliche zuwendung die unternehmen wie
die lufthansa aber auch kleine kneipen
oder friseure retten krisen wie corona
scheinen einen aktiven start zu fordern